welcome back to the five Fox News has
just confirmed that president Trump's
top economic adviser Gary Cohn has just
resigned president Trump said this Gary
has been my chief economic adviser and
did a superb job in driving our agenda
helping to deliver historic tax cuts and
reforms and unleashing the American
economy once again he was a rare talent
and I thank him for his dedicated
service to the American people and this
statement out from mr. Cohn it has been
an honor to serve my country and enact
pro-growth economic policies to benefit
the American people in particular the
passage of historic tax reform I'm
grateful to the president for giving me
this opportunity and wish him and the
administration great success in the
future
all right Kimberly he came from goldman
sachs and great pedigree they're very
successful on Wall Street and he was
considered what people say in the White
House who didn't like him a globalist
meaning not an American nationalist more
concerned about the world economy and
not necessarily a defender of the
American manufacturing base and had a
lot of internal fights with some members
of the administration and some people
are now speculating that he may have
long resigned in the wake of president
Trump's saying that he's going to enact
steel tariffs what do you think okay so
I think that he's obviously a highly
competent individual he was well
regarded at Goldman Sachs I say it's
fair to say that people thought that he
was a more of a globalist that term has
been used and I think that's you know
he's somebody obviously they wanted to
serve the country worked very hard in
there the president liked his
organization and he would present like
charts with him and like different
color-coded and he liked that so I was
very organized
I like organization Dana Perino likes
organization so that I think is very
good if he felt that you know he had
kind of provided the opportunities and
the help and the assistance to the
President and to the country and his
work was done there that's one thing and
I mean the president made a tweet this
morning put out a tweet that said there
may be some staff changes and thinks
coming in the future I think this is one
that was expected there's been
discussion about Cohen McMasters and
chief of staff John Kelly so you
one of those people already now leaving
you know the president I'll also note
that you know he's always been very
close with Jared and Ivanka as well and
that was kind of like a triumvirate
right there that the three of them were
together and probably coalesced on some
you know of the issues he wasn't a big
fan proponent of exiting the Paris
climate change Accord so that was also
probably part of the reason why people
would you know framed him in that
fashion as a globalist but he certainly
knows the economy and he was very
helpful I think to the president you
know in that regard and now you see well
they'll bring in some some new people
because what is the president Trump do
always hires the best people what I mean
how many people come and go in this
admit and they come and go so quickly I
mean to me what Kimberly said about
Kushner is right forefront now because
he was seen as part of the Kushner wing
of the Trump Whitehouse and cushion area
obviously is on very thin ice having his
security clearance downgraded can't
really function properly in this White
House and charges of nepotism larger
than ever Wall Street Journal telling
him go back home well I think you're
probably moved to the campaign side of
the pronounce this campaign and then
we'll stay but I'm saying that seeing
Gary Cohn Gary Cohen so widely respected
on the economic side now out it just
says to me boy you know we say oh don't
play the chaos oh it's not so bad it is
chaotic in this markets might not like
this yeah but I think here's one thing I
think that he's been a loyal public
servant in that when you said that a
globalist cares more about the global
economy than the American economy I
think he would say that that's not true
I think that what they're he's resigning
on principle because he cares about the
American economy and the accomplishments
of this past year especially with tax
reform when it and and the dreg piece
actually very much helped the United
States economy and just on principle
decided to resign and that's when you
know you have a loyal public servant if
you feel that you I've given your best
advice well I guess what you're sorry
but you are the the president is the
president I'm only here I can give you
the my best advice and if you don't take
my advice if I feel strongly enough
it is a bad decision and I should resign
and I think that we should welcome that
it doesn't always happen that way in
Washington and he had a good run Greg on
the economic side that he did that he
did a typical globalist would say that
Dana but no the point the point is I I
mean if you want if no no point is if
you want cheap goods to foodtube for
people to or goods that people can
afford and you want to spread the wealth
if that makes you a globalist and you're
a globalist this is I'm so tired of that
phrase I think the phrase has been it's
become some kind of knee-jerk thing to
say what Trump isn't but the fact is
we're all globalists we all are micro
dreamers we're all dream
we're all globalists dreamers but the
biggest this really is about I think
protectionism and I think you know he
was a big proponent of free trade
obviously Cohen was and the problem with
populism one day you Zig the next day is
zag you know it depends on what's
popular what you know what people like
and I think you know you know when when
when you know Trump will say he's a free
marketer but then he will talk about
protectionism they don't say well I'm
about fair trade and I think Cohen was
kind of hoping he knew this was gonna
come up but he was hoping it wasn't
gonna come up this quickly meeting
tomorrow with consumers of still
products are trying to change the
president's mind and one of the
realities of last week was that he was
supposed to have the ability to review
and talk to the president before the
decision and president just did it